I was reading about the battles Battle
of Harpers Ferry in the Civil War tell
us about it
it's just the town of West Virginia and
I think the Confederates just like wiped
out the Union or I don't know I I don't
know a lot about it but I was looking at
it and it's like this little town but I
think it's on the Shenandoah River and
it is yeah and so I was just reading and
I was thinking of like when all this was
going down during the Civil War and like
Union forces would ever went to a town
and just like started firing how long
would it take someone in New York to
fight to find out that happened a month
it's a really good two months in fact
they kept fighting certain battles after
they were like done they'd been won
because they had no way of communicating
right right
that's what I'm thinking like back then
all this stuff would be going down
people in New York and DC would be like
oh so they go about their lives like
normal yeah nobody would be making
weapons nobody would be freaking out
there'd be no propaganda there would be
no protest marches now it's like some
dude in Minneapolis dies and people in
London start rioting and smashing
windows yep it's like that's not even
the same country dude so now yes I
wonder about this stuff you know yeah it
is kind of interesting though because in
in Britain they they like paid they had
their citizens pay to free all the
slaves in they just finished reparations
yeah so it's like it's never gonna be
enough dude exactly you see the moment
you see the video of the cop laying on
his belly with his hands behind his back
and let someone yells it's not enough
it's not enough to lay on your stomach
and like surrender you know what dude
yeah it'll never be enough I don't know
that and I don't know the UK paid
reparation that's crazy yeah yeah they
plan it out the problem with the u.s. is
that you can't simultaneously talk about
how our nation's a nation of immigrants
and then want everyone to pay so so if
you're gonna say that you know they've
talked about how would you actually pay
reparations you'd have to like trace
back lineage lineage do the same thing
for for the family of slain boner slave
owners that's true yeah like what why
does my Korean family have anything to
do with this right good point
nothing that's there in fact they were
trying to flee the the slavery and stuff
that was going on in their country so
leave me out of it but that's what you
get me
now we're seeing just radicalization and
I wonder if it's like you know it's it's
we saw the Democrats earlier you know
kneeling yeah and that's just like they
they're there they may not be entrenched
in the fringe cult but they're like
adopting the symbols now like wearing
you know they wore the candy cloth or
whatever they're trying to yeah the try
it and and that's and that's it's
seeping into the mainstream and this is
where it gets scary man when you start
seeing the ideological enforcement of
law this racetrack in North Carolina
wanted to put on an event and so they
defied the governor with a big f you the
governor basically said you can't do
this so they held another event and said
it's a protest now
now now we're protesting inequality and
the governor is apparently pissed off
like striking back and it's like no no
no no no you can't you can't go out and
March with protesters and say the
protesters are okay and then get mad if
I do a protest the way I want to do it
right so that's where this is where
we're at there they're literally trying
to enforce the law against anyone except
those who had here to their ideology
that's messed up yeah it's real mint
does not make any sense I mean it does
if you're in a cult and your cult is
taking over okay
yeah then you're a lot because they know
it's not about like you mentioned
they're out riding in London but they
just paid off the reparations yeah boys
I said a lot of people in the chat I
just was reading it it's like it's not
that they were represented be free so
they bought them essentially they bought
their freedom yeah and let them be free
and it's taken a long time to finally oh
I finished paying all of it off so they
avoided so through taxes yeah so it's
like they've been paying Wow but it's
it's they helped pay for their freedom
so you know sure it's not reparations as
the traditional what we think that we
owe them but it's like what else could
they have done they helped free them
yeah they gave them their freedom and
then yeah that's messed you know you're
not thinking hm III decided I I
completely agree with reparations man Oh
100% okay yeah I think the Confederacy
should be forced to pay for all of the
all the slavery so if you you know reach
out to those Confederates and let them
know they owe you money yep oh I mean us
oh no we
the ones who not my family actually
because we weren't here but the Union
the union that one yeah yeah well
they're the ones who paid to literally
fight a war to free the slaves so and
and and I say that's almost facetiously
because I actually do think there's some
things we can do
I think reparations the one wrong way to
go about I think should be class-based
but I do think generational wealth is
creating a massive disparity which
causes racial tensions and problems that
needs to be fixed about well I I thought
about this after our show last week
about talking about how cities aren't
are not they just can't work cities you
know and then I'm like alright so how do
we solve that how do we we can't just
suddenly you know give these people that
you know the poor folks in cities plots
of land everywhere because we'd have to
take it from other people you know so
what is the answer there it's like
really it's it's not an easy answer you
know but part of what we should figure
out how to do is get people land you
know make communities we got a whole
bunch of empty space create creatures
yeah create communities outside of
cities that people can live in learn how
to grow on the land you know not oh
people to live there not have to pay to
live I think that makes a difference I
got bad news though what I had a
conversation on Facebook with friend of
mine and I made that point about cities
I thought like I think the real problem
is that people are stacked on top of
each other you've got police who don't
care yeah and then she was like Tokyo
it's not that police don't care it's
that they deal with so many different
people know that you you see the bad in
that instance is this is the point that
she brought up what Tokyo why is it that
Tokyo has none of these problems and
they have ten times three times the
people and why is that they're racially
homogeneous boom yeah and then I brought
that up I said yeah you bring up Tokyo
but that's it's it's ethnically and
racially homogeneous right no no she did
and she's like a lefty black lives
matter activist and she said she was
like spot-on exactly which shows that
there are tensions between races in New
York City that need to be solved
because you have disproportionate
amounts of so more white people and
Latinos are killed but relative to the
population more about black people are
killed okay now you've got different
arguments from different rupes as to why
that is somewhat argue the police are
racists
I mean and Bloomberg literally said he
sent the cops into that neighborhood
reason but then other people bring up
that you know more crimes are committed
in these neighborhoods which I can
easily point to class issues and not
race yeah but but she agreed she was
like you know yeah there's there's
something that they don't have and
that's the different you know races and
stuff and I was like so it sounds like
you know we are a multicultural
civilization we have these racial
tensions that don't exist in ethnically
homogeneous cities yeah so right right
off right right from there you'll hear a
lot of the like I don't know I don't
know what group two would represent this
idea the best I'm not gonna name anybody
but they want to balkanize like separate
all the races or whatever okay I think
that's ridiculous
so they want to bring back segregation
no balkanization what's up so like all
of one race would be put in one state
all of one resident in another state to
separate everybody in fence it out is
that not exactly what segregation is not
segregation was like there will be one
movie theater with two bathrooms and one
for different people okay so you live in
the same city but bring it up to a
larger scale it's the same thing so
you're you have to go you have to live
in this state you're not allowed to live
in that state yes all the vulcanization
won't they sound awfully the same to me
segregation would be like you can come
to the pizza place and different races
sit in different different areas okay
yeah also I'm saying it's just a bigger
version of it yeah I guess
thank sort of I got it I know I'm
accepted we can move on no no I mean but
balkanization is about literally
creating like separating countries yeah
yeah so that you can make sure the races
don't interact with each other ever yeah
so their different function so create
the divided States of America yeah yeah
I think that's stupid I think I think it
is fair to I think you know it's you
know it's funny and like what's messed
up about this argument that I can't
stand is that the left and the white
supremacists are completely agree on
almost everything except like what what
what the left doesn't understand is
they've never actually listened to a
white supremacist speak okay
so I was talking to a friend of mine who
was saying that white supremacists think
that white people are killed more by the
police and I said that's not true there
are conservatives who will point that
out and hey more white people are killed
by cops
but when you actually listen to the
identitarian Spee it widened into terian
black identity aryan or whatever
they'll tell you yep we agree completely
on all of it I was talking to my friend
and I said do you know what the 1350 is
yeah I'm familiar with it it's it's it's
a phrase often brought up by like white
nationalists right I'm saying that and
actually there was a there's a viral
video right now from I think I think
this was in Brandon stocks video the one
it's going viral we mentioned uh yeah he
said the black the black population is
13% of the US but accounts for 50% of
all crime or whatever and so I was
trying to explain to my lefty friends
that when they mentioned the
disproportion at policing against black
people I'm like that's literally what
white supremacist spring up but they
they think there's a different cause for
it right they're just arguing about
cause yeah and I was like the people
you're talking about like are an
imaginary group of people like the the
lefty friends I know like literally just
make up this conservatives in their mind
like I know this one dude he posted
something of a guy it was a meme where a
guy is saying it's a comic he's saying
if they didn't want to get shot they
shouldn't have gone out for curfew and
that's him sucking on a boat and I'm
like where did you make that person up
yeah like like that's ridiculous
like I know there are some dumb people
on Twitter who say things kind of like
that but it's like you imagine this
person in your mind who you think it is
and so now you have all these like
lefties who are actually bringing up the
same points as like I guess the easy way
to put it is black lives matter is a
black identitarian group so they believe
a lot of the same racial tenets and
ideology is like white identity Aryan
groups yeah if I just don't you realize
it anyway the point I was bringing up is
when you look at what's going on in
cities like New York where you do have
these issues
if you've hyper focus on how Bloomberg
handled things you'd say the police in
the city are racist okay if you hyper
focus on the areas where crime is coming
out of you'd probably think it was a
race-based issue and then if you try and
look back and look on the data and
realize that poverty is the driving
force generational wealth disparities
combined with people like Michael
Bloomberg right and try to figure out
these problems are instead a giggle
situation instead what you get a bunch
of people who can't see beyond step one
and so the only thing they say is racism
or race yeah you know definitely not
well that that's our opening rant for
the mo
good opening rant yeah but we're gonna
so so anyway I'm you know even got there
I was talking to friend on Facebook
that's how it happened the reason why is
because it is it is what is on
everyone's mind right now
right exactly this this is what's
happening we have to figure something
out you know you know everyone deserves
the right to have a life you know I've
got everyone so if there's people out
there that that are rightly pissed that
they're not getting equal rights as to
live then we need to figure something
out
well there there can't be it's just it's
just that's the problem and it's not
right now that's exactly my point right
now that we cannot especially living in
a city yeah yeah right exactly there's
just there's so many different facets of
what needs to happen to solve this all
you know where do you even start you
know how do we even know about that the
problem is complex problems require
complex solutions yeah but we are we are
a planet of very simple people very few
people have have powerful enough minds
to calculate complex issues I think the
problem is that no one person can tackle
it I don't think any one person can
handle a problem like this I don't think
any idea is good enough because I think
it's at a cultural level and I've been
thinking about these problems for my
entire adult life and I've come to the
conclusion that you don't solve cultural
problems I don't know how to do it I
don't think there's the way to do it
yeah maybe there isn't maybe maybe it's
just there'll always be some problem no
matter what we do like you know it's
funny to me right now that's a lot of
these young people like the fake
tourniquet thing yeah remember so we
talked abouts a little while ago there
was a video from a riot some do got hit
in the leg with a rubber bullet he got
enough he got a surface level a
contusion a surface level man it was
like he was bleeding but it was kind of
like yet yeah I saw it
it wasn't it wasn't bleeding that bad
right it was barely open an open wound
but it wasn't even bleeding it was not
even that big of a deal it's like have
you ever been skating like my legs are
covered in scars I don't even want to
think about my legs
yeah my ankles on fire I almost got that
hardflip how's it good almost but I've
had I have a dent in my shin bone no
from getting whacked with a skateboard
and it dented zebrova it's probably
permanent oh okay I did you in ten years
yeah mine are more like mountain ranges
yeah anyway anyway yeah these kids put a
tourniquet on on this leg this like we
put on wrong and they put all their
weight into strapping it and that's just
like you you you're dumb you're gonna
lose your leg here's my I bring this up
it's like is this it we're so desperate
for some kind of adventure
maybe that these kids are like are you
gonna put a tourniquet on this and it's
like you know it man
well they're lashing out at anything and
everything this is why you see the
antiva types wearing all black throwing
rocks at cops it is live live-action
roleplay is a little dismissive that's a
weak weak a LARPing yeah yeah and it's
it's they try and throw it back at like
conservatives which doesn't make sense
because the 45 year old guy standing in
a park reading a prayer is not LARPing
anything literally living yeah I was it
I was in Portland and that's what
exactly was going on there yelling Nazi
LARPers and I'm like no they're
literally doing a prayer surface like
they're actually living you guys are the
one who think you're fighting Nazis when
these guys are just literally reading a
prayer service yeah that's how bored
life is so so we have this video from
Seattle well his aunt Eva dudes are
throwing rocks and bottles at cops I
tweeted about it there's no constructive
end to what they're doing right there's
no point where the police are like oh no
we've been defeated on the streets wheel
hereby disbanded a cop the cops wearing
a helmet
then another cop comes back and it's
it's it's just ridiculous mm-hmm it's
like somebody being mad at a bank so I
think they show up with a spoon and
they're banging on the wall with the
spoon and you're like I'll show you and
it's like you will literally never do
anything to that building with the spoon
or they go and like mug the cashier yeah
it's like that's right I showed those
bankers since like that's just a regular
person window sure there's nothing
constructive to that I mean you can
argue that it demoralizes the police I
guess yeah but come on
barely you know so these kids are going
out
esprit for something anything to feel
important that's I mean we've been
that's been lacing our show since we
started the show about people not having
something to live for
yeah people don't have that anymore
that's we need to give that to humanity
no humanity need to give to itself these
people had bad parents well I'm saying
we as as a human you know I mean like I
felt like it took me a while to find you
know what I want to do in my life and I
honestly I'm still I didn't even this I
just stumbled upon this you know and
this is this is great but you know I
like my music or whatever it is it's
like it's something to work towards you
know we need to you know we all have to
come together and figure this out we
can't say one person's gonna figure out
the answers and then if someone doesn't
have an answer you like you can't just
cancel them we got to have a
conversation about it you know it's like
well we got to open it up and talk well
no the cancelling is about them having
no mission that room why that's why they
often attack each other that becomes
their mission to just cancel it because
you don't even you don't believe what I
believe I'm just gonna can't see you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
if you want to catch the full show tune
in to this channel subscribe hit the
like button or check us out on iTunes
and Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you